首先先到EEKS這邊
那等一下會用到GitHub
所以你們的GitHub要把它開啟
那我們現在先登入GitHub
那我為了要跟大家同步
我先另外一個瀏覽器
登入另外一個GitHub的賬號
好 這個登入了 成功
那再回到這邊
那我們點選上個星期的這個GitHub連結
先點進來
0916課程裡面的PyGNT繪製地圖
進來之後呢
我們現在要做的是第三個部分
AI探索與作業
化世界的板塊交接帶
就直接點這個連結進去
裡面會有這個作業要怎麼進行的說明
那我把這個連結放到E-Class的作業2裡面
這樣子同學要找的時候會比較方便
所以你要進行作業2的時候
也可以參考一下這個連結
這個連結直接點進來就有那個攻略
攻略就在這邊
那這個作業呢
他說前面兩個作業我們已經用
Notebook
Jupyter Notebook
來畫臺灣地圖
而且有畫出地震的分佈
那接下來我們要
要做的事情是要把
要看全世界
的地震分佈的情形
那我看一下他怎麼寫
他說前兩份用
Jupyter Notebook
練習了會畫臺灣地圖跟地震
的深度還有地形
那我們現在要把這同一套方法
搬到世界上的其他地方
然後選一個板塊交界帶
畫出海底地形跟地震分佈
然後再切一條剖面
從剖面上的地震分佈來證明
或者來說的證據來說明
它是屬於哪一類的板塊交界帶
那下面每張範例圖對應的程式呢
可以告訴AI來做
然後你可以用兩種方式來跑
那怎麼開始呢
第一步就是先Folk
程式的Repo到自己的電腦
然後最後也是把這個網址交給老師
就是你的作業就完成
那你的你畫的圖啊
還有你的一些分析的資料
材料也都可以放到這個repo上面
那他說有兩個方法來做這個作業
一個就是用本機
一個是用雲端的方式
那我們選擇用雲端的方式來做
這樣比較不會受限
就是你一定要帶著筆電在那做
應該說帶著同一檯筆電在那做
你就任何一個可以上網的筆電
或者是桌機學校的電腦
你都可以連到那個雲端空間
然後去寫作業
所以我們現在用第二個
會比較有彈性
好
那我們就真的要照他的步驟來
我在家裡有自己
有try了一遍
今天早上
然後是OK的
所以我們現在一起來進行
這個這件事情
那首先就是
大家的GitHub要先準備好
GitHub
好
GitHub先準備好
然後
然後 再來就是 再回到這邊
然後他說 我要開一個 Notebook
然後第一個要按照作業儀的那一套去安裝
然後第二個要Git clone自己的Folk
第三個要Run這個程式
這三句話我們其實都
大家應該會覺得有看沒有很懂
不知道在講什麼
那我沒關係 我來翻譯給大家看
然後大家一起來做一遍
大家就會了
你們就會了解
好
我們先
我們先做這件事情
Folk
Folk他老師的
的Repository
先來做這件事情
什麼叫做Folk
Folk就是把他的
Public的專案
把它複製一份到自己的
的Github賬號裡面
好
這怎麼做呢
我們從那個EE Class上面
可以看到老師的專案在這裡
所以我們就先點他的專案
這個是老師的專案的網址
然後點進來之後呢
你會看到這裡有個按鈕叫Folk
你就直接按下去就好了
你就會把這個專案
copy到你的電腦裡面
copy到你的賬號裡面
GitHub賬號裡面
我示範一次給大家看
但是你一定要有一個前提
就是你一定要先登入好
你自己的eHub賬號
像我現在這個瀏覽器
我已經登入好我的eHub賬號
已經登入好了之後
你就在這個瀏覽器上面
然後貼上上星期
Jimmy老師的Repository
這個是他的Repository
前面有他的名字
後面是他的倉庫的名稱
然後右邊這邊
你可以看到我現在是用我的賬號登入
所以我是用我自己的賬號去開啟它的倉庫
那它的倉庫其實不需要登入也可以開
因為它是公開的Public
所以前提就是你要先登入
然後你再去網址開啟它的專案
然後接著就按這個按鈕Fork
按完Fork之後
他說我現在要建立一個新的副本
Folk
然後這個Folk
他的名字會叫這個
一樣的名字
但他現在Owner是我的賬號
然後確定沒有問題就Create
Folk
然後接著你就會發現
他現在同樣的名字
但是前面的Owner變成我的
所以這個專案變成我的專案
不過如果你點進去的話呢
你還是會看到這個專案是從
Jimmy的這個專案Folk過來的
Folk from這個專案
所以它的源頭還是會被記錄在這裡
但是現在這個專案已經在我的賬號底下
不管那個Jimmy未來有沒有把這個專案移除
或者都不會影響到我
已經
有這些程式跟檔案
所以第一步就是要先Folk它
然後我這邊其實可以看到大家有沒有按Folk
因為它這個數字會一直往上增長
剛剛看這個Folk的數量是8
那現在是13
所以已經有五位同學
可能包含我都在裡面有Folk它的專案
所以同學可能還有很多人還沒有按這個鈕
所以現在還沒有辦法fork
那是不是請助教幫我
幫我看一下同學們
這個動作呢
有沒有問題
就是你先開啟你的
你的github
然後要登入
登入完之後
你就去連那個
居民老師的
網址
連完之後呢
就直接按這個fork
他就會將你的
將他的
端案
copy到你的
帳號裡面
OK
好
可以嗎
對
現在這應該是你的帳號
然後你就直接按focus
然後直接
create
這樣就好
OK嗎
OK
這邊有問題嗎
弄好了
好
這個
先往
先回到最上面
這是他的,然後你已經登入
對,按這個
現在你綠色的
這邊
OK
對
可以嗎
開啟就好
對,要focus
這是
這是他的,然後你已經登入了
點那個Folk
先回到Code
然後點這個Folk
直接點他,不用按那個
然後再按綠色按鈕就可以
這邊OK嗎?
Folk,按了嗎?
有按,好
這個我跟他不一樣
我跟Folk,跟Folk
因為你已經切到你的帳號底下
但是你的帳號底下就是在轉完沒有的資料
對啊 我們都知道你
這是基於你的專案
好 大家都完成了
等一下 我再確認一下
應該都完成了
好 接下來我們再回到專案的
我們現在可以看自己的專案了
就是大家可以確認一下你的左上角
這裡是自己的賬號的名稱
然後專案的名稱是PiGMT
那我們可以點一下code
然後回到這個code的主畫面
那也可以看到這個專案是從Gimi的PiGMT來的
所以這些資訊是正確
Gimi就是上星期授課的老師
好那接下來我們去點這個3
AI探索與作業
我們要繼續follow他的步驟來進行
好這裡有一個怎麼開始
我們剛剛已經把1做完了
Poke課程repo
clone到自己電腦
好現在我們要進行第二步
第二步呢我們選擇這個co-lab這條路
然後它說第一格要照01的環境格安裝
我們就點一下這個01的環境格點一下
那它會幫我們開啟一個新的Google Colab
Google Colab就是一個Jupyter Notebook的環境
可以讓我們執行Python程式
那它的缺點就是它每次開啟都會跟新的一樣
就是你要重新
從第一步執行到最後一步
因為它的那些變數都不會存在裡面
不過它是一個免費的
可以執行Python程式的一個雲端空間
然後它能夠跟GitHub聯動
所以剛剛這個圖呢
其實還有還可以多一個
就是Google的Colab
Colab本身就可以run Python程式
而且你可以直接改直接執行在上面
然後你做完的這些結果跟程式碼修改完畢
你可以把它寫進GitHub的某個專案裡面
或者是你也可以從GitHub把專案的內容
把它clone到Colab裡面
所以它可以直接跟GitHub互動
然後可以做程式的操作
所以大家又可以再一次看到
這個CopyHub的強大的地方
有太多東西都可以跟它互動
然後可以直接存取
好 那現在這個東西
這是Gymi的IPYMB檔
已經進去了之後
我想想看
因為它的連結是寫在它自己的
所以我們要把它
我們先把它做完好了
他剛剛說我們
剛剛那一段字不見
我們要保留第一格
因為它的環境是第一格
第一格要保留
然後其他不用保留
這裡有一句話
就是第一格照這個的環境安裝
所以後面的我們都不用保留
所以這個地方呢
我們把後面的
我們可以把後面的刪掉
或者是把第一格的內容
copy下來
有兩個做法
所以我們先
我們把第一格copy下來好了
我這邊如果有做完
我也可以把我做完的那個分享給大家
這樣大家就可以
可以繼續用這個去follow
所以我們要把第一格把它
扣下來
然後我們可以在檔案裡面
開啟筆記本
開一個新的
新的IPYMB檔案
在雲端硬碟中建立新筆記本
然後大家要先登入你的Google賬號
應該大家都有登入
我們現在這個方法就是
我們要用Google Collab來寫程式
那Google Collab
它是Google的一個產品
所以要先登入Google賬號
然後我們可以在
這個現在是Google的賬號底下
然後開了一個寫程式的一個空間
那我們可以先
把上面的檔案名稱改一下
因為這個是作業2
HW2
然後是Geophysics
作業2
這樣子
好
那你要用別的名字也可以啊
這個名字大家隨意自己
我把剛剛
的這一段程式碼把它貼上來
因為剛剛剛剛君秘的
的那個
指引呢告訴我們要把第一段把它扣下來
因為這一段就是用來
準備安裝你要跑拍GND的那個程式碼在這裡
所以我們把它扣下來
然後可以按一下這個按鈕先
先讓他RUN一下
看看他有沒有辦法正常安裝
他這個Collab
他現在有分三個頁面
右邊這裡會顯示一些資訊
然後這邊是程式
然後左邊這邊可以顯示你的檔案的內容
那我們可以先把右邊這個分頁關掉
這樣會比較大一點
所以現在大家應該可以
都應該要先有一個這個檔案
那這個檔案就是開在你的
Google的雲端硬碟裡面
它現在它看起來裝的沒問題
已經裝好了
然後我教大家一下
怎麼樣去生成新的格子
因為你下面可能還要寫新的程式
你就點一下這一格
它就一格一格去執行
然後你可以點這個加程式
然後它就會在下面多了一格
然後再點一格
就會加一個
所以你就可以開始在下面
接著打別的程式碼
所以這個是第一個程式碼
第一個程式碼主要用在安裝環境
那你這邊用完之後呢
你可以把它儲存
那有另外一個重要的就是
你可以把它存在GitHub
在GitHub中儲存副本
所以我們可以點一下這個
那這時候就是Colab要跟GitHub連線
就是這一條線
Colab現在要跟GitHub連線
必須要你給它許可權跟授權
所以我們現在要給它許可權
那看起來它已經直接可以
好像有抓到我的許可權
那我猜因為我這邊已經有登入GitHub
然後又登入Google
所以它直接就去抓這個
但他現在抓到的這個專案名稱
不是我的專案名稱
我們的專案名稱是這個
這是GMI的
我們的是用了很多個
所以必須要搜尋一下
這個HiGMTMapLab
這個是我們的專案
這是我的名字
所以在這邊要去找一下那個專案
太多就會很難找
好喔對好
好那記得分支都是 main
這樣他就會
我們就維持一個分支就好
不然會太複雜
所以這個確定是對的
這是我的
然後我的專案名稱
然後在 main
然後這是這個檔案
然後就確定
好然後就可以看到他已經寫進去了
在這個裡面呢
專案裡面呢
有一個
檔案就是這個
他已經被寫進來了
可是他還沒有
轉出來
哦在在這裡
檔案在這裡
所以我我剛剛用了一個很簡單的方法
讓他連線
在檔案然後儲存
在 github 中儲存副本
然後選到
這邊要選到我存放區要選到我們的專案
名稱裡面
然後按確定分支要用面
然後按確定之後呢
他就會把這個目前這個檔案
直接送到這個
我的eHub裡面
然後你可以看到
這裡已經多出了這個檔案
當然它就可以一直保留在裡面
這個就是你的作業的部分
然後接著再回到這邊繼續編輯
第一步就是先
這個已經做好了
這個就可以關掉了
這個可以繼續用
第一步是把安裝環境設定好
第二步看一下它的指示
是Git clone自己的Folk
這句話就是說
把Git hub裡面的這個專案裡面的程式
把它全部搬進來
collaborate來
叫做Git clone
所以我們現在來做這件
這個步驟
所以它的指令就是金碳號
然後Git clone
然後我們把它放到這一個
Git clone
然後後面要空一個
要告訴他從哪邊clone過來
那我們回到這裡
那要看仔細哦
不要clone到GMI的
我們要clone自己的
所以這是自己的
然後這邊會有一個code
點下去
這裡就是你的git clone的那個網址
我們把它按一下copy
再一次哦
就先確認你自己的
然後再來點這個code
然後再來就會看到clone
clone就是複製
大家有沒有聽過一個電影叫克隆人
就是克隆這個意思
克隆就是複製
然後我們把它這個網址複製下來
然後再回到這邊
就是金碳號Git
然後空一個克隆
再空一個就是後面這個網址
然後我們就執行它
執行旁邊這個按鈕按一下
就可以執行它
好 這樣做完之後呢
會發生什麼事情呢
我們可以看一下最左邊這裡
有一個按鈕叫檔案
點下去
然後你就可以看到你目前的檔案裡面就有
這些東西
我打不開
我讓他重新整理一下
重新整理他就重來了
所以再我再重來
再重新再轉一次
好有有他出現了
所以可以看到現在在CodeLab裡面
已經有這些檔案了
那這些答案就是剛剛
從GitHub上面clone過來的
好
我先把它做完
然後等一下我再試出一版
就是已經都做好的
那同學直接開啟就可以用了
這樣子可能會更簡單
然後我們再看下一步
所以現在一
第一格做完了
第二格也做完了
第三格要run這個程式
所以我們把這個程式扣下來
這個程式扣下來
然後貼到第三格
但現在去run這一格呢
你會發現他說
他會說他找不到這個檔案
file not found
那這個檔案我們要幫他找一下
他在examples的目錄裡面
這裡examples目錄裡面的02
所以是這個檔案
然後這個檔案呢
我們請他給我們路徑
複製路徑
所以我可以變成run
run這一行
這樣子他就會找得到檔案了
他沒有拍GNT
還沒裝好
可是他看起來他環境沒有裝好
我想想看
那這個要再回去這個第一個
我用我用他的來來run好了
大家先試一下
然後等一下會把我整個試好的那個版本
再丟給大家
然後然後大家可以就可以用那個版本來執行
那我們現在先看一下
第一步做完
然後我先多兩格
然後第二格要clone
第三格要run這個指令
為什麼還是沒有
那我們請AI直接來幫我們解決這個問題
他說在執行這個指令碼的時候
找不到PyGNT這個函式庫
雖然之前的步驟已經安裝
Conda Collab並啟動執行環境
但PyGNT函式庫本身並未安裝
我們將安裝派GNT和GNT的指令
加到這個儲存格
確保在執行指令碼前
裝好必要的函式庫
所以這裡就是它的安裝過程
安裝完之後再去執行這個程式
可以等它一下
然後這邊可以選擇用
比較高階的模型
就是訂閱值可以用Pro
然後這邊有它的使用量
現在用了5%
將於星期四上午10點45重設
看起來也還好
一天24小時就會重設
所以這個還可以
還蠻好用的
因為我知道他會裝這麼久
上禮拜有裝這麼久嗎
上禮拜在跑拍GNT的時候
後來都有裝起來
好
那我們先放著給他跑好了
有可能是那個網路
因為大家都不太好
那這個先給他跑
我們先看一下另外一個部分